Yuji itadori just unlocked incredible
new powers that will allow him to go
head-to-head with sukuna yuji's body
seems to be learning to use sukuna own
innate technique just as Gojo predicted
all the way back in chapter 12 I don't
think I need to tell you how much
stronger Yuji will become when he learns
to use sukuna curse techniques and
that's just the beginning Yuji has the
ability to hurt not only the body but
also the soul which he proved in his
battle against mahito mahito confirms
that Yuji possesses a unique
understanding of the human soul in
chapter 222 we saw Yuji apparently
switching his soul with kusakabe and we
know that yuji's Soul managed to survive
the death of his body for an extended
period of time before being revived by
sukuna this suggests that Yuji has a
secret innate technique that allows him
to manipulate souls and this is the
secret weapon that he will use to defeat
sukuna for my full video on yuji's new
secret power click the related video
right now and don't forget to subscribe
to anime uproar